Grant has decided that he wants to diversify his product base. He's created a
new kind of wiper set to add to his glasses family. This is the Deluxe Duo, a
set of glasses wipers unlike any other every created. They have superior wiping
power and non function curly qs for decoration on the ends of them. With them.
Now, as silly as these glasses wipers might seem to you or me, Grant has a
reason for creating them. He can charge a lot of money. In fact, of just one set
of deluxe duo glasses wipers, he can charge $75. This is big money in the
glasses wiper business. If we let the number of deluxe glasses wipers sold equal
m, and Grant's total profit in dollars from them equal p. Then I've created an
equation for you that describes his profit based on the number of deluxe glasses
wipers he sold. You know $75 is how much he charges per pair of deluxe glasses
wipers, and $5000 is the amount of money that he had to put down to invest in
the materials and everything he needed to start building these. So, we have an
equation, and we have a wonderful product.